thank you Yasser we are with abrahamian
Tate first of all congratulations you
started off against the two top rated
players in the event Irina Christian two
draws how would you assess your
performance
um I mean I'm happy with my results I
had two shaky games I mean my game today
was pretty damn uneventful but at some
point I just couldn't make any decisions
and I got really long time so I think
let's talk about it
I've had experience yesterday let's
discuss this game for a brief moment
okay tell me about the key moments
I I just I don't know I
I was just so tired today on honestly I
just couldn't make moves but I mean
there's not much here
I play here I went B6 I mean did you
feel like she was putting any pressure
out of the opening
four when she took Bishop F6 I thought
it was pretty simple because now all of
a sudden all my moves now I have to
think about like C5 and then okay we go
for
did you discuss with her did she know
about this no because she came straight
to you I didn't get a chance to talk to
her after but yeah she spent some time
she started thinking and I was actually
wondering what she's thinking at that
[ __ ] out of my page for her but she's
gonna have six and then F6 Knight takes
F6 yeah now all my pieces they go I
think
on their squares and then here we just
repeated efficially six absolutely quite
a uh smooth let's say start the
tournament this is a very long
tournament 13 Rounds uh how did you
strategize your preparation coming into
the event
to do anything specific anything special
um I have some like opening ideas
clearly I haven't played it
but it's a long tournament so I think
important segmentally to get ready for a
long tournament and I don't think it's
very important to press for a win every
round I mean at my point I might regret
this when I have too many draws but I
think at some point people will start to
be a lot of battles and um 13 Rounds
people will start getting tired
something at some point something will
happen absolutely guys enjoying the
conversation yes first of all I wanted
to say to tattoo that she's my Peak and
you said that you were a little bit
tired but I hope that you will find the
energy and will like move forward first
of all and I felt your supportness thank
you thank you but really if you need any
support of it of course even extra
support so but I wanted to ask you about
the game yesterday that one at certain
point you got your chances
um it looked really like promising for
you the final position even like what
did you feel at this moment how did you
assess this position
yeah I mean that might be a decision I
regret because I had to make a concrete
decision to go for this Rook end game
and I couldn't calculate it out and I
talked about it after without 105 and
they both feel like of course like
you're the only one pressing you have to
force her find like critical decisions
even if you see it in your calculation
but like I calculated I couldn't find
anything concrete and then again I
started thinking too much and then I was
like okay like I don't wanna
spend too much time and then get into
some kind of weird Rook end game some
something that I mean again regret so I
decided just to repeat
but what a nice sexual possibility then
that you had the chance to analyze it
with Fabi and Alejandro actually
[Laughter]
come on guys uh what did I do wrong are
they uh helping you are they training
you in this event at all or is just a
casual conversation we're just we're
just hanging out again yeah just looking
at
it this is what happens when you're in
St Louis
some random Grand masses you just catch
them
okay thank you thank you and all the
best thank you
and uh speaking of a lady play